les sondages décrivent des citoyens
désenchantés par la politique
abstentionnistes potentiels
et si certains français exprimer leur
citoyenneté autrement
je vais vous raconter l'histoire de
trois citoyens ordinaires engagés dans
un combat colossal la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
[Musique]
alexandre annie roux leur problématique
c'est la surconsommation de tous et donc
c'est ça qui est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui depuis depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale c'était
nécessaire mais mais depuis on n'a pas
changé de modèle et je pense qu'on est
vraiment arrivé au bout et que ça c'est
souffrir
[Musique]
xavier miroir si on attend le politique
règles on peut toujours attendre il va
rien se passer donc c'est soit on râle
c'est la peur pour faire avancer les
choses ou se dit bah tiens on se prend
en main on fait les choses telles qu on
a envie de les réaliser soi même on y va
alice bornes je passe mon message
j'essaie de le passer au plus grand
nombre parce que plus on sera nombreux
et plus les actions seront palpables et
si nous les citoyens on est des choses
en place il ya des choses qui peuvent
changer
ces citoyens pèse sur la vie de la cité
par l'action ils influencent les
décisions politiques
jusqu'à pousser les portes des
ministères et citoyens sont là pour pour
nous titiller pour nous solliciter on
voit qu'à préoccupation environnementale
est très forte après ce que des citoyens
attendent de nous en tout cas ce qu'ils
me disent c'est que il attend de nous
qu'on mette les cadres et qu'on donne
les moyens de le faire
nos déchets
alexandra xavier et alice les ont pris
pour cible ceux produits par notre
consommation et conséquences du mythe de
la croissance infinie
rebuts de notre civilisation
voyage chez des français qui font de la
politique sans en avoir l'air
[Musique]
à
mon voyage m'a mené sur la plage de
l'espiguette
pas l'ombre d'un touriste nous sommes à
la mi décembre
rendez vous avec sa vie murard
moi je constate c'est de se dire on peut
faire les choses on peut les faire
changer mais voilà faut passer à
l'action quoi vous aviez a pour ambition
de nettoyer la mer tout simplement
voilà quoi une pince âge-là je pense ça
doit être une bassine saut
voilà c'est un emballage ses écrits en
chinois dessus en anglais donc je sais
pas ce que c'est et ça au fil des années
ben ça devient tout petit quoi on a
autant des problèmes de pollution liés
au micro plastiques qui vont aller sur
les
les animaux marins quoi donc ça peut
monter dans la chaîne alimentaire ça
peut être ingérée par des poissons et
ainsi de suite et ça bah ça va faire en
meurent quoi
270 mille tonnes de plastique colonisent
les océans de la planète
l'équivalent d'un nouveau continent
vous aviez agit en mer méditerranée
une véritable cuvette de déchets à
l'automne les cours d'eau ont débordé
prendre tous les déchets qui sont sur
les rives ou autre ça fait comme un
effet de chasse d'eau donc c'est comme
ça qu'on se retrouve avec tous ces
déchets dans la mer méditerranée
ça arrive de partout quoi
à tintin c'est pas tout staff s'est
pressée plastique
cela c'est 6 et plastiquement séparons à
la déchetterie du grau du roi ça déborde
et le plastique est indestructible
voilà ce qu'est ce que c'est malheureux
mais c'est la réalité quoi c'est ce
qu'on trouve
voilà des choses comme ça
des fois on trouve aussi la date donc on
a des choses qui datent de des années 70
en état parfait quoi commença à des pots
de yaourt des années 70 avait écrit la
date limite
c'est assez effrayant
pour son projet
xavier a quitté son emploi il ya cinq
ans avec une conviction le plastique est
un puissant vecteur pour questionner
notre civilisation
le déchets marins va apporter une
émotion dans une émotion ça va permettre
de sensibiliser plus globalement à la
problématique des déchets si on prend
une déchetterie
dans les terres bas avec des déchets
partout autour bape ça va ça peut
interpeller certaines personnes ça peut
choquer bien évidemment mais pour la
plupart personne ne voit le problème est
là en mer les gens ils vont aller à la
plage siwa de 3 déchets sur la plage
mais là ça va choquer et si ils
monteront mouvement une une tortue ou un
animal en mêlée dans des filets ou dans
du plastique ou autre là ça choque et ce
plastique on se demande pourquoi il est
là et là c'est toute notre société de
consommation qui interpelle et là on a
des messages à faire passer c'est ça qui
est fort
son projet s'appelle recyclons
xavier cherche à fédérer autour de lui
tous les protagonistes possible pour
mieux collecter et valoriser ce
plastique
[Musique]
dans le bord du grau du roi je vais
faire connaissance avec jeff breau
def
bolloré comme tous les hommes de la mer
ils ne pêchent pas que des sols des
daurades
dans ses filets il y à vous vous en
doutez les déchets
[Musique]
ça c'est la mauvaise pêche du jour on va
dire
ça c'est le match facile ça c'est la
journée du client la vie tu es déjà avec
les grosses pluies qui a eu et ce qu'il
a déversé le rhône on n'a pas eu pas mal
d'arbres et pas mal de plastique
d'un côté les pêcheurs ramasse
gratuitement de l'autre l'agglomération
du grau-du-roi leur met à disposition
des poubelles spéciales s'était
construit avec paul le projet est coincé
de devoir déjà s'ils ramenaient des
déchets et puis nous on dit spontanément
qu'ils ont ramené et après de voir
qu'ils qu'est ce qui pourrait être fait
avec avec eux pour que qu'on mette les
choses en place quoi tout simplement
quoi nous c'est c'était c'était obligé
quand elle accepte cela l'acceptent pas
ça c'est du n'importe quoi on est
directement impacté donc maintenant
c'est qu'il faut c'est que les autres
ports fasse part et de partout qu'ils
fassent pareil ça serait bien
sa vie a pour ambition d'étendre cette
collaboration
ailleurs en france
et il va falloir convaincre
près de la moitié des plastiques servent
à fabriquer des emballages et si on s'en
passer
la personne que je vais rencontrer s'est
donné pour mission de les réduire pour
ne pas avoir à les détruire
elle s'appelle alice bigorgne
alors on est dans votre épicerie ici ou
fait la chasse aux emballages ça
exactement c'est une épicerie en vrac
qui couvre l'ensemble des produits du
quotidien vous allez pouvoir acheter
avec vos contenants ou ce qu'on peut on
met à votre disposition
pour alice utilisé une nouvelle
enveloppe à chaque fois qu'on consomme
un produit est absurde mais matières
premières puiser pour la fabrication des
emballages ne sont pas infinies et après
il faut encore les recycler ceux qui
consomment aussi de l'énergie
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
vraiment urgence pour nos enfants et que
c'était faisable et facile à donkey
décéderait utiliser un maximum les
contenants qu'on a à la maison
dans sa boutique alice s'élèvent contre
le gâchis son sillage le vrac permettent
aussi d'ajuster ses achats à ses besoins
et dans un premier temps cela on est
presque déstabilisant j'ai l'impression
que je suis un peu perdu au niveau
quantité combien d'agents prendre quand
on a plus de d'emballage de poids
exactement alors c'est vrai qu'il va
falloir s'habituer petit à petit en fait
on se rend compte des volumes qu'on
consomme et puis là à la rigueur pour
tous qui a apéro ou confiseries c'est
sympa que voir varié donc plutôt
qu'avoir un gros paquet vous êtes en
train de me dire que vous faites la
chasse aux emballages et au gaspillage
exactement c'est exactement ça
alice rech évangélise convertis et
explique comment changer ses habitudes
de toujours
vous aidez mesdames
en fait l'idée c'est de ne prendre que
les quantités dont vous avez besoin en
réutilisant maxime un peu contenants et
appâts niveau mais il vous faut un quart
des pierres à café d'une église
comprenez que ce qu'il vous faut
sa boutique est située dans un quartier
populaire de lille on est loin du cliché
du client bobo bio souvent décrit pour
ce type de consommation l'ate mille
doses sur le feu mon engagement c'est de
promouvoir cette envie de consommer
autrement c'est cette envie de faire
changer les choses par des actions
concrètes parce que tout le monde
consomme pour se nourrir
moi je rêve que demain en bas de chez
nous y ait que des épiceries en vrai on
a on est mieux à faire avec toute
l'énergie qu'on dépense pour créer ces
emballages
enfin les ingénieurs sont bourrés
d'idées donc on pourrait faire plein
d'autres choses plutôt que
revoir la forme ou la couleur du bouchon
de
l'emballage des pistes par exemple
en france chaque foyer jette plus de 52
kg d'emballages plastique par an mais
comment s'en passer complètement
l'emballage est aussi une protection
pour transporter nos aliments
même chez alice
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui c'est jour de
livraison
mais bien sûr je rende d'être une pompe
à essence de flocons d'avoine et d'avoir
un jour un camion citerne qui viennent
me livrer remplir directement mais beck
en revanche ce que vous devez savoir
c'est que nous si on tient compte de nos
déchets on doit vous permettre à vous
diviser par 20 les vôtres ceux de la
maison allez on emballe
les géants de l'agroalimentaire commence
tout juste à se mettre à emballer en
gros volumes ans ils sont désormais
motivée par la croissance constante du
marché du vrac même en temps de pandémie
qu'ovide remarqué cette marque de pâtes
aux sachets bleu et blanc elle s'est
mise il y à dire que moi a changé son
process de fabrication pour emballer
différemment alice peut désormais la
vendre ils n'étaient pas intéressés par
notre marché s'est pas manifesté il ya
six ans donc là c'est tout le travail de
notre centrale d'achat aussi un de
d'avoir cette relation avec des
fournisseurs avec des marques françaises
est prêt à jouer les jeux du gros
contenants donc là on démarre avec cette
marque et je vous cache pas que c'est un
grand succès
en six ans alice a prouvé que son modèle
pouvait être viable il y a quelques mois
elle a ouvert sa troisième boutique dans
l'agglomération lilloise
[Musique]
certaines de nos ordures n'en sont pas
vraiment
nause épluchures de légumes non pelures
de fruits nos restes de repas un tiers
de nos poubelles domestique on les
appelle les biodéchets il intéresse une
jeune femme partie à la conquête c'est
un nouveau territoire
[Musique]
elle s'appelle alexandra niro bonjour
avec son bar merci de nous avoir
rejoints alors là on est en plein coeur
de bordeaux on peut pas être plus au
coeur donc on est sur le pont pierre
lieu parfait pour faire du vélo et aucun
récit de nos collectes sont à des
adhérents sur les deux rives
alexandre a fait des tournées pour
ramasser toutes ses épluchures dont
l'hyper centre ville là où elles sont
mélangées au reste des déchets dont la
poubelle du tout venant
aujourd'hui le non sens serait que les
bio déchets sont incinérés et les
biodéchets sévit majoritairement de
l'eau donc en fait on brûle de l'eau
aujourd'hui dans les incinérateurs
les biodéchets c'est essentiellement le
bas les épluchures ccsn pour son
flottant fêté en fait aujourd'hui c'est
brûler et ça ça demande une énergie
folle de brûler blanc et
le plomb et fait le break très
convaincant
dans le coffre de son drôle de vélo des
sceaux utilisé depuis des siècles au
japon ou en amérique du sud
dessau qu'on appelle des bokashi
le fameux son beau gâchis
et donc leurs souvenirs en fait tout à
fait il est muni d'une grille au fond et
d'un couvercle hermétique
donc c'est la différence avec un pinceau
classique et donc on comme celle les
liquides et les solides vont pouvoir se
séparer mais bonjour ça l'ex membre et
que pour le mot caché sur 20 les
habitants chez qui alexandra collecte et
y soit 110 euros par an et 4 euros par
un massage
un public de convaincu 500 foyers à
bordeaux ici allons tous leurs
sur les épluchures des granulés mâche le
travail
entre chaque couche de déchets on vient
mettre ça pour tasser dessus et donc
c'est des acides lactiques c'est la même
chose qu'on utilise pour faire la
choucroute des légumes là que fermenté
du pain du fromage est juste on
l'utilisent pour les bd chez pour
ralentir la putréfaction faire en sorte
que ça moisissent pas et donc on puisse
le garder chez soi plusieurs semaines
sans contrainte et c'est ça pour vos
flèches du voka chien sur un crime comme
ça c'est combien de temps à peu près que
vous mais pas confié alors la dernière
fois je pense que c'était il ya deux
mois quelque chose comme ça ouais ouais
donc vous allez garder très longtemps en
fait et on le soin aux points il doit
faire au moins 10 kg face à lui écoutez
moi je trouve pas que ça sente mauvais
rebond des franchises non ce sont les
plus sûres il se sent pas la pourriture
mais c'est la fermentation des déchets
pour mener son projet
alexandra a fondé récup là encore une
association elle se versant smic et
emploi de jeunes en service civique
[Musique]
regardez la tournette ce soir
une application optimise le tout et
surtout les tournées
récup collecte 50 tonnes de biodéchets
parents à bordeaux et sa métropole
une goutte d'eau par rapport aux 87
mille tonnes jeter dans leurs poubelles
par les habitants
même si c'est une petite goutte d'eau je
préfère est une goutte boxe à cette
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça peut-être
que c'est cette goutte d'eau et cette
action en plus qui va faire changer les
choses on sait jamais peut-être que nos
petites actions au fur et à mesure vont
enclencher un mouvement est un vrai
changement au niveau des politiques
publiques au niveau 2 de l'organisation
de la ville et promouvoir du coup une
agriculture locale des jardins partagés
des composteurs partout en ville donc
c'est pour tout ça que je fais ça le
projet d'alexandra et globale
[Musique]
elle imagine un autre monde où le
dessein de ville serait source de vie
[Musique]
voici le jardin de caroline mutuelle
la maraîchère fait pousser des légumes
en biodynamie
aux aucun engrais chimiques
alors qu'est ce que vous faites là
alexandra je suis en train de récupérer
tout le juch les aideront pas conservés
chez eux parce que logis du bocage qui
est extrêmement nourrissant c'est un
engrais très puissant qu'il ne faut
jamais utilisé pur d'ailleurs un
de façon pour l'instant artisanale
alexandra travail à ce qu les épluchures
deviennent compost
donc là je fais le mélange entre les
vieux déchets et et le voyage dans six
mois on ne reconnaîtra absolument pas
les légumes on ne reconnaîtra pas le
broyat tout aura été digérée par les
micro organismes qui sont dans le bocage
y voilà
et tout finira dans le demi hectare de
potager
mais quand j'ose dire à alexandra
qu'elle valorise des déchets elle me
reprend immédiatement
c'est pas du déchet le déchet c'est ce
qu'on met à l'incinérateur nous on
continue le cycle de cette matière qui
se transforme au fur et à mesure qui va
devenir du sol et qui va permettre de
faire d'autres légumes c'est assez
puissants comme comme sensation que
c'est à dire que d'un côté en bêta nizon
bête embêté sommes tous partout pour
construire construire construire en
artificialisés message et nous on n'en
reconstruit à partir de quelque chose
qu'on appelle du déchet à la base
plutôt fier de créer du seul
dieu
[Rires]
avec son drap imagine une boucle
vertueuse d'une part la production
agricole des campagnes de l'autre les
besoins alimentaires dix villes et leurs
déchets tout cela dans un périmètre tout
proche
ça paraît un peu utopique ça paraît
utopique puisque on a décidé de faire de
l'économie les nerfs depuis toujours où
on achète on consomme en jette
mais justement faut on est en train
d'essayer de faire changer ça il ya de
plus en plus sur tous les sujets
l'économie circulaire qui sent vite et
donc donc non on va y arriver et enfin
le compostage c'est quand même vraiment
quelque chose de très naturel et simple
à faire c'est juste ne pas jeter dans la
poubelle noir jeter à côté et enfin
mettre dans une autre boite et ensuite
nous on s'occupe du reste
d'aucuns pourraient prétendre que son
action est minuscule mais elle veut
inspirer les pouvoirs publics
bientôt une obligation légale pourrait
bien faire avancer les projets
d'alexandra
à travers mon voyage j'ai cherché à
comprendre ce qui avait mis ses citoyens
en action pourquoi subitement alors que
rien ne les y prédestinait il s'était
mis à faire de leur vie la lutte contre
nos déchets
[Musique]
delphine est la compagne de xam jean
lechasseur de plastique en mer
vous êtes zéro déchet on essaie mais pas
complètement zéro déchet on essaie de
c'est de faire ce qu'on peut ouais
c'est l'allemand comportement petit à
petit
photo avec papa et maman
tous deux se sont rencontrés il ya 20
ans il était alors étudiant en
environnement
tient regarderai montrer vraiment avec
tes tortul up car là c'est le cocktail
les cocotiers le sable la plage l'océan
la tortue et l'arc-en-ciel et maman
derrière c'est pas le top ça c'est une
tortue verte les magnifiques delphine
travaille à la protection des tortues
marines
c'est papa sur un chapeau à son ancien
travail papa et voyagez beaucoup il
allait partout ça c'est en mer rouge au
regard d'alexandrie ah oui elle en est
endémique au dessus d'avis que pour le
boulot que je faisais pour une mission
là c'est au mozambique
up à tagab hélas le canal de suez ah
ouais ça c'est marrant regardes tu vois
là on dirait que le bateau il est dans
le désert en fait ces îles et sur lola
irrational
beaucoup de pays différents dans les dix
ans oui énormément de voyages ouais
ouais c'est vrai que je partais beaucoup
en mer donc forcément et c'était un coup
en afrique en amérique du sud en asie
en europe du nord voilà c'est c'est un
peu partout les traversées en mer aussi
entre la de l'amérique golfe du mexique
jusqu'en écosse où là d où donner de la
norvège juste dans le golfe persique
voilà c'était c'était des missions vous
habitez oui on habitait également à
l'étranger puis après on habitait en
france et après c'était des missions
pour partir pour partir en mer fernand
la topographie marine
à l'époque il avait un salaire très
confortable et des collègues
sympathiques mais à l'aube de la
quarantaine il a eu besoin de changer de
cap
la topographie marines étaient de la
géophysique pourvoir en fait ce qu'il ya
dans le sous sol donc généralement c'est
des applications énergétiques soit du
pétrole du gaz ou quoi donc voilà le
côté chercher du pétrole ben là il y
avait un petit problème d'ancrage voilà
mon prêt pour le reste
bah disons fait des études
d'environnement et puis après ans finit
à chercher du pétrole donc on se dit on
n'a pas forcément envie de faire ce à
quoi voilà donc donc du coup cette
partie sur sur vos sites lampe voilà
c'est parti comme ça
xavier a beaucoup cherché avant de
trouver sa voie
j'ai appris qu'ils avaient 0 fils
chez marin les filets de pêche tous ces
sujets là je me suis dit mais c'est pas
possible il revient en france et j'ai
commencé à regarder ce qui se faisait à
l'étranger j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
petites choses c'est bon c'est parti on
va lancer un truc en france et voilà le
déclic il a été là c'était mollahs
c'est aussi au tournant de la
quarantaine qu'elle est devenue la reine
du vrac
elle a brutalement quitté son poste de
directrice marketing pour une marque de
prêt-à-porter bon marché
alice a eu une sorte d'overdose de trop
plein
oui
c'était précisément au moment où son
entreprise fêtait l'anniversaire de la
marque y est arrivé un moment où ce que
je faisais n'avait plus vraiment de sens
pour moi sans savoir l'expliquer et là
je me suis rendu compte que bah ouais
commander des goodies pour
l'anniversaire de la marque c'est quoi
l'intérêt quoi est ce qu'il vaut mieux
pas utiliser cet argent pour promouvoir
un nouveau mode de consommation pour
aller parler dans les écoles pour passer
ses messages de d'actes citoyens de
changement
cette prise de conscience remonte à 2015
date à laquelle j'ai rencontré et
interviewé alice pour un premier
documentaire sur les emballages
après avoir quitté son emploi de
directrice marketing elle avait décidé
de transformer sa façon de son mi
mai en 2015 alice manqué de choix de
produits la vente en vrac n'existait
quasiment pas en france
la limite de ces choix là elle le fait
pour les moins de produits
à choisir un conseiller des produits de
qualité
en 2015 elle faisait un peu l'effet
d'original à force de balade et se boit
de vie décès ou sont issues chez tous
les commerçants bio
ça marrant de voir ces images parce que
c'était vraiment c'est vraiment le
démarrage de notre de notre démarche
là on le voit début du reportage on
n'avait pas beaucoup de choix on le voit
dans les épiceries contient aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup plus de choix on peut se
faire plaisir sur plein de choses
on n'est plus obligé d'aller dans un
seul magasin ou le boucher vous regarde
pas bizarre parce que vous n'avez votre
super voir allez y en a plein qui
acceptent le truc en a qui font des
remises fin je vous sens prêt ce qui lui
en fait de repères c'est
en fait ce qui est émouvant c'est de se
dire qu'on est rentré dans un truc qui
semblait pas si facile que ça il ya six
ans et en fait six ans plus tard c'est
toujours là et ça fonctionne toujours
donc bah ouais c'est la solution quoi
servent les solutions
alice a converti toute sa famille au
vrac elle a surtout élevé et ses deux
filles pour générer le moins de déchets
possible
[Musique]
le moteur s'est montrée aux plus jeunes
les bons gestes parce que pour nous il
est entre guillemets un petit peu tard
nous les dégâts sont faits on peut juste
essayer de se donner bonne conscience en
rattrapant le truc pour mes filles il
faut que ça devienne des
rituel des habitudes de consommation
enfin le moteur oui c'est quel avenir
pour mes enfants
plus tôt
[Musique]
moi si je schématise un petit peu j'ai
presque été élevé dans le caddie du
supermarché parce que dans les années 70
le supermarché est arrivé avec ses
solutions de consommation rapide et
efficace là on est en train de faire
marche arrière quoi y'a rien qui nous
impose en fait notre manière de
consommer on fait un peu ce qu'on veut à
nous de boycotter des trucs qui nous
plaisent pas je suis libre de choisir
d'aller au supermarché ou pas je suis
libre de choisir d'acheter des vêtements
seconde vie ou pas voilà
notre adepte du beau gâchis elle puis
dans cette maison de centre-ville en
colocation
pas de sonnette
et voilà c'est un nouveau no
merci de nous recevoir chez vous en tout
cas
alexandra c'est l'histoire d'une bonne
élève son père travaille dans
l'industrie automobile sa mère élève si
trois enfants il y a deux ans la jeune
femme obtient un master en économie du
développement
étudiante elle a déjà lancé son
association moi j'ai été élevé en milieu
rural donc petite fille d'agriculteur et
la nature a toujours eu une place
importante j'ai toujours une maison avec
jardin et le compost faisait partie
intégrante de notre quotidien on fait et
c'est et la corvée quand on était petit
de sortir sous la pluie en bottes pour
les bd le composteur et maintenant j'ai
passé mon bac et après je suis parti
faire mes études en ville pas du jour au
lendemain j'ai tout vidé dans ma
poubelle noir et
et ça a été douloureux mais ce n'était
pas naturel en fait tout simplement de
juste basses mettra jeter ses déchets en
sachant que ça allait rien de venir
dont la colocation alexandra est la
benjamine
les autres sont trentenaires
électricien ingénieur mécanique de
travailleurs sociaux
je perçois une génération en quête de
nouveaux modes de vie sur fond de crise
climatique
si on a envie de continuer à vivre un
peu un peu heureux faut mettre des ans
remplace d'elle chose qui marche et on a
plein de choses à voir monter enfin je
pense qu'on a on a plein de choses à
revendiquer dans ma génération et dans
men se dit est-ce que ça sert vraiment à
quelque chose la tâche est tellement
immense bâche sinon dont se crever non
je fais pas franchement s'ils n'ont
aucun sens dit ça on n'a pas honte de ne
pas sens à notre vie aussi et parce
qu'on est des êtres humains on va on a
besoin d'avoir un sens dans l'oubli et
ça ça me donne en tout cas actuellement
mais on peut se dire à la fois à
l'échelle mondiale ça va pas changer le
monde après tout mais en même temps ça
change vachement les relations qu'on a
tous les jours avec m environ avec les
gens qui nous entourent et ça c'est
vraiment ça compte vachement donc
la vraie problématique c'est la
surconsommation
de tous et donc c'est ça qui est un vrai
problème aujourd'hui alors qu'on peut
vivre avec un peu moins et tout en étant
tout aussi heureux et si une forme de
gravité inquiétudes aussi dans votre
combat
au début oui quand on se rend compte
qu'il ya un vrai problème avec de
réchauffement climatique et de
d'extinction des espèces étaient des
rails de tout ce qu'on entend sur
plastique et tout ça au début il ya une
vraie il ya une vraie urgence et une
vraie tristesse qui est qu'ils arrivent
mais soit on décide de juste d'être
déprimé et d'aller vivre en autarcie au
fin fond de la campagne
soit on décide de vivre au milieu de
tout le monde et d'essayer de changer
les choses à son échelle
en
vendée
au fil des mois je me suis demandé
comment allait évoluer leurs projets et
quels rapports ces trois citoyens entre
donnait-il aux politiques
[Musique]
c'est sur la côte atlantique
que je vais retrouver xavier
[Musique]
six mois après le grau du roi les
pêcheurs de la ville des sables d'olonne
sont prêts à collecter les plastiques en
mer
ce jeudi là se tient l'ultime réunion
pour passer à la phase opérationnelle
sa vie est un peu tendue ou pour que ça
fonctionne on a besoin de tours on
savait pas la complexité en même temps
du projet autour de la table deux
personnes de l'agglomération des sables
d'olonne
un représentant des pêcheurs
et surtout un chaînon capitale paul
clément le recycleur qui traitera les
plastiques en bout de course
mais très vite arrive est la question
qui fâche
la gare par contre j'ai pas tout à fait
tout compris pour ça le financement
c'est à dire aujourd'hui par exemple sur
les mobilisations de la baie le
déplacement de la mer
c'est le recyclant qu'il a sur ses
ajustements cinquième jour sinon c'est
bon c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
xavier bafouille car il doit leur faire
comprendre que c'est à la ville de payer
la facture tout dépend de paul clément
l'industriel qui va recycler le
plastique et de son devis un chiffre est
lancé le projet coûtera moins de 1000
euros par an
après les élus dit tout à fait favorable
au projet donc là à moins de 1000 euros
par an je pense que ça va pas les
inquiéter du tout et leur donner encore
plus envie de participer au projet
grand oral valider
les sables d'olonne adopte le projet
rien d'étonnant en définitive selon
xavier ce ne serait que le résultat
d'une certaine pression de l'opinion
publique
comme j'ai dit aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment on a qu'à voir les
manifestations toutes les marches tout
toutes les initiatives qui existent des
tout ce bouillonnement quittiez la
autour de ça et ça c'est c'est un bruit
de fond qu'il progresse qui grossit et
aujourd'hui les gouvernants ils vont
devoir prendre ça en compte ses obligés
dans son projet xavier a l'ambition de
suivre la filière jusqu'au bout
les déchets ramassés en mer
vont finir au centre de tri de paul
clément
tous collectivement nous produisions des
montagnes de plastique
ici plus qu'ailleurs on s'en occupe avec
soin car pour les recycler il faut
d'abord y mettre de l'ordre
c'est ici qu'on trie du plastique en
quantité 3000 3500 tonnes par an par an
donc ça fait
[Musique]
c'est effrayant là c'est le tsunami ya
la bague qui s'écrase là c'est effrayant
et tout le monde devrait voir ce ce type
de site c'est ces foules tout ça
normalement ça doit partir à
l'enfouissement ou à l'incinération et
là tout est trié et chaque bout de
plastique va être valorisé
le plastique c'est compliqué et aux tpe
hd pvc en fait il y en a sept grandes
sorte pour les recycler il faut
absolument les trier par catégorie parce
qu'on ne sait pas encore faire autrement
c'est un peu comme si vous essayez de
recycler du verre et de l'aluminium
mélangez ça ne marche pas
une fois séparés les uns des autres il
ya encore du travail
le broyage et le lavage
un plastique c'est un peu comme une
pâtisserie en plasturgie ce qui va faire
un gâteau et pour faire son gâteau il
faut la bonne farine et un nous on s'est
préparé la farine en fait entre le
plasturgiste et et la farine il ya le co
founder qui va rajouter un peu ce qu'il
faut là dedans pour perd 7 soit
excellente pour une société qui va
recycler ces plastiques à en palettes
localement on a vraiment tout un
programme aujourd'hui c'est atteignable
il ya deux ans elle n'était pas
et bien voilà le produit final qu'on va
préparer ici ce qu'on appelle de la
paillette nous donc c'est du
polypropylène sais quel type d'objet
likoud rabat sous lucé très court en
attendant une dans une maison c'est les
bassines l'eso
l'appel ordures c'est très très très
trop donc là on prétend faire tomber ça
c'est la taille est 2 psg donc là
vraiment la destination et sarthe pour
refaire des tuyaux directement
[Musique]
là on est sur un gisement de pétrole
dur
pas besoin d'aller en arabie saoudite où
je sais pas où on l'a ici en france et
après on arrive à le valoriser en faire
quelque chose ça qui est génial
un gisement de pétrole qui doit devenir
rentable devenir objet pour avoir une
valeur économique
c'est la conviction de xavier
[Musique]
mon voyage me mène en catalogne je me
rends dans une usine impressionnante que
s'apprête à découvrir xavier
ici les granulés de déchets plastiques
vont être transformées ceux là sont
tombés au t2 l'ancien bouteilles d'eau
xavier a rencontré michel che pas un
autre français qui croient en la
deuxième vie des déchets vous avez
derrière vous enfin derrière xavier plus
tôt vous avez des silos là on vient
mettre les granulés de matières
plastiques recyclées qui vont ensuite à
rentrer dans un process d'extrusion et
ensuite de filature
xavier découvre que le filateurs
espagnol a investi pour assurer une
fibre recyclée avec les mêmes qualités
qu une matière plastique
pour que le recyclage s'impose à long
terme ce fils doit intégrer des filières
économiquement intéressante
ce qui m'a plu dans cette affaire c'est
le dire on va aller chercher les
compétences parce que moi vous aviez
murard j'ai pas les compétences c'est
comme ça qu'on s'est trouvé avec michel
pour transformer le déchet c'est cela
l'important c'est que chacun a un rôle
dans cette chaîne de valeur et pour que
ça fonctionne il faut marcher avec des
professionnels et qu'ils savent faire
leur métier
là c'est vraiment qu'un filet après là
c'est un mélange de film
et ça commence à fonctionner des
centaines de marques utilisent déjà
cette fibre espagnole pour avoir une
image plus verte auprès des
consommateurs il ya des vêtements bien
sûr par exemple vous montrerez mais là
il ya les serviettes de bain voilà par
exemple et vêtements à travers des
matières qui contiennent main du fils
sic oil donc ça c'est de la mousse et de
l'habillement vous avez dû jean aussi du
denim par exemple qui peuvent être
développés donc ça s'est fait en espagne
a été que s'ils sont faits en espagne
sur ses chaussures ya du fils qui vient
d' easy en fait oui oui c'est du fils
recyclé d'accord 100% recyclé issu de
déchets soit post consommateurs soient
déchets sauvages collectés dans la mer
et on en a refait un produit avec une
valeur ça s'est déplacée qui suit dé
cher mais ça c'est du polypropylène
c'est des nouveaux matériaux ça c'est du
polyester et l'entrain de travail de
nouveaux matériaux correspond à d'autres
déchets
et ses d'autres c'est d'autres
industries sai d'autres technologies
c'est d'autres besoins ces deux
impératifs techniques mais c'est la même
méthode le même modèle donc ça veut dire
que là on est plus sur le textile comme
sur d'autres applications
pour réduire l'impact de nos déchets
tous nos produits du quotidien devrait
être fabriquée avec des considérations
d'éco-conception
l'éco-conception ça veut dire que les
entreprises doivent trouver des
solutions sur les matériaux issus de
leurs process pour ne plus utiliser un
matériau vierge mais non seulement
intégrer des matériaux qui ont été
recyclés et de pouvoir aussi à
développer des filières qui leur
permettent de vous deux que leurs
produits soient recyclables donc c'est
pas simplement dire à un produit et
recycle et sept produits recyclés mais
qu'ils soient recyclables et là il ya
des enjeux de terribles on prend pas nos
responsabilités
c'est à dire on le sait forcément quand
on produit quelque chose on sait qu'en
fin de vie ça va être un problème et ça
ça jamais été évoqué donc c'est simple
de faire des produits ça c'est pas un
problème mais de gérer leur fin de vie
c'est nettement plus compliqué
du déchet plastique au produit
xavier est allé jusqu'au bout
il a réussi à fédérer des énergies du
monde de la pêche des politiques et des
industriels
[Musique]
dans le petit univers des épiceries en
vrac
alice a été une pionnière
cuire
ces mêmes il a été fait en fait pour
prendre appui sur le mur et on a fermé
l'accès à la cave aujourd'hui didier
honneur et apporte le projet plus
globalement il était à la tête d'une
franchise ya vu les esprits s'éclairer
au fil des années pour en 2018 ya un
vrai vrai changement je dirais que tout
ça comme un 6-2 à la montée du mouvement
greta tanberg où on sent que là ça
commence à secouer très fort sur la
jeune génération qui se pose beaucoup de
questions et qui a envie d'action et
puis simultané avec le départ nicolas
hulot qui dans notre pays est en effet
un petit peu d'électro shot sur une
partie de la population et la politique
se réveillent et commencent
véritablement à s'intéresser au sujet
dans la foulée didier honneur et à
fondre réseau vrac un groupe de lobbying
qui entend bien compté dans le débat
public
[Musique]
à la suite de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat le projet de loi climat
et résilience a été votée
et réseaux vrac a été associé aux
décisions
barbara pompili la ministre de la
transition écologique veut obliger les
grandes surfaces a proposé 20% de vrac
d'ici 2030
direct au réseau vrac fait partie de
ceux qui ont permis d'apporter cette
petite expertise supplémentaire pour moi
c'est vraiment à un grand coup
d'accélérateur
de enfin avoir un objectif dans le dur
de la loi n'est plus juste a un objectif
théorique dans la loi il va falloir
qu'ils aient 20 % dans les grandes
surfaces qu'ils soient consacrés au vrac
mais est ce que c'est un projet de loi
qui est difficile à porter et vous est
ce que vous sentez aussi des réticences
à parce qu'effectivement il s'agit de
gros changements en réalité il est
résistant il ya toujours des résistances
parce que il ya le réflexe qui assez
classique de la la on n'aime pas trop le
changement c'est ça ce sont des
résistances à ces classiques et puis
après il y a des encore une fois des
peurs réel sur sur le coup aussi que ça
peut engendrer que ce soit pour les
industriels mais aussi pour les
consommateurs des résistances doit y en
avoir aussi parce que le vrac est et
sera mobilisateur d' espaces de manière
beaucoup plus importante que ne l'est le
pré emballés et puis il ya probablement
encore quelques voix qui vont apparaître
parce que ça fait disparaître la
visibilité des marques ou en tout cas
salini mise donc on voit tous ces chants
de résistance qui font exister les
impôts
dans ses échanges avec la ministre
réseau vrac a été moins loin que les
propositions remises par la convention
citoyenne au président de la république
loin de ces tractations alice elle
préfère agir sur le terrain consciente
d'avoir semé une graine il ya six ans
une graine qui a bien géré mais
l'idée c'était d'amorcer quelque chose
et de faire en sorte que que ça bouge et
ben oui ça bouge en 6 ans et à bouger et
même quand on est dedans on a
l'impression que ça bouge pas assez vite
mais si ça bouge c'est utile c'est
donner envie à plein d'autres d'ouvrir
des épiceries comme ça c'est à donner
envie à plein d'autres même alors des
citoyens qui se sont dit mais oui c'est
comme ça qu'on doit consommer qui s'y
met mais aussi aux grandes surfaces
aux politiciens qui l'air de rien de là
haut nous observe quand même et se
disent tiens c'est quoi ce truc
finalement c'est peut-être utile et est
aujourd'hui c'est le cas
le
et où en sont les bokashi
depuis des années nous sommes habitués à
voir nos cartons où nous plastiques
collectés séparément
bientôt ce sera le cas pour les
biodéchets
toutes les villes devront s'y mettre
autant dire qu'alexandra espère que
c'est beau gâchis soit de la partie
11 juin 2020 bordeaux traditionnellement
à droite a vu un écologiste remporter la
mairie
ça change des choses le changement de
couleur politique pour vous à la mairie
en tout cas on l'espère durant ce mandat
ya l'obligation réglementaire de tri des
biodéchets qui va arriver donc il va
nécessairement se passer des choses vous
avez des questions en tout cas oui tout
va des questions sur comment comment il
voit
cette obligation arrivé en 2023 dans
quelle mesure on voir nous appuyer sur
notre développement même chose
alexandra redoute que son association ne
fasse pas le poids face à véolia ou suez
les géants du ramassage dont la bataille
des marchés publics qui aura lieu dans
quelques mois
elle espère un appui du maire
aux tonnages sont tellement minuscules
travail pour la capacité des autres
grands acteurs que l'on peut très vite
se faire étouffer alors on peut il pour
vous aider pardon on a service
développement économique et on peut
faire une sorte de essayer de fédérer
toutes ces associations tous ces acteurs
qui travaillent autour de cette filière
entre non pour et aider les acteurs
d'entre eux à ceux à se rencontrer et à
échanger à s'unir même par rapport à ça
peut marcher je pense que c'est aussi le
rôle de métropole et des services
développement économique de métropole
qui donc travaille beaucoup c'est bien
sûr c'est le secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire n'a pas solutionné
n'y a pas de solution en ligne ce sont
des micros solution en plus on les
expérimentons va pas sans celle ils sont
émus les plus efficaces moi je trouve ça
très bien
déchets reçoit un peu plus un peu plus
la d'initiative un peu plus émouvant que
la collecte traditionnelle le camion qui
s'adorent je vous la poubelle grise
en attendant
alexandra développe son concept
ici le beau gâchis créer du lien social
au coeur de ces logements hlm débute une
expérimentation étonnante
au milieu des tours un jardin partagé
entre eux tenus par un habitant
le croyais qu'on avait reçu assez
et alexandra en pleine explication
auprès de l'émissaire du bailleur social
c'est ça
jonathan client lui l'habitant jardinier
est un converti
clairement le beau gâchis c'est la
matière première c'est sans ça moi je
n'ai pas de sol reçoit faut que je
l'achète donc en fait c'est je récupère
le beau gâchis je le travaille à bruges
la mène ici en fait on les thalys y est
bien le roi y lit encore sur toutes les
surfaces et en fait c'est tout bénef
quoi
le seul aussi on évite qu'ils soient
trop sec grâce royale droit qui a encore
pas trop transformé dans notre idée et
je pense quand même rien développé avec
ou cachés avec jonathan avec les villes
des idées du pouce car et bordeaux
métropole c'est vraiment proposer aux
habitants d'avoir un outil simple pour
pouvoir composter tous leurs déchets
l'hydroptère qui pourront voir et un
arrosage ou est ce qu'il va être
valorisé c'est à dire sous leurs
fenêtres dans le jardin qui est animé
par d'habitants du quartier et autour de
saint prix au pays basque des tas de
choses n'a validé ses effets assez
d'être de pousser le lien à son maximum
en permettant aux habitants de se
retrouver autour d'un sujet qui à la
base est pas du tout de l'amour qui est
le déchet
et de faire en sorte que les gens se
rencontrent échangent et enfin on parle
de plus en plus de café compost de
discussion autour des bacs de compostage
ce soit pour venir vider soit pour venir
tourner soit pour épandre donc s'il y
avait un petit carré de pommes de terre
donc comme vous le voyez en fait c'est à
quelques plants de pommes de terre donc
j'attends les prochains enfants qui vont
dire et je le redis l'asie et ya il sera
content et verra les pommes de terre
dans la terre s'il veut il part avec
quelques-unes s'est fichée dit ah
oui ici
[Musique]
chacun à leur manière tous partagent le
sentiment tout le citoyen est le moteur
du changement
et le politique dans tout ça
il faut du citoyen mais après le
politique doit prendre ses
responsabilités ça c'est évident
aujourd'hui tout cas ça serait temps
qu'ils montrent en tout cas leur
engagement et qu'ils fassent preuve d'un
peu plus de courage et de volonté sur
sur certains sujets mais c'est très
compliqué je pense qu'on est nombreux a
pu attendre grand chose des politiciens
en revanche si nous les citoyens on met
des choses en place
et on embarque avec nous bah oui ça peut
il ya des choses qui peuvent changer il
ya des choses qui peuvent évoluer qui
vont davantage correspondre
à ce que ce que nous les citoyens on
attend et ce qu'on veut voir évoluer
souvent c'est il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se passent par le bas ou à force de
pressions et d'action citoyenne ont fini
par changer les choses
vous pensez ça vous ne pensez pas qu
aujourd'hui le moteur et le politique ça
va dans les deux sens la convention
citoyenne pour le climat elle n'aurait
pas eu lieu sans les juges
le résultat aujourd'hui est pas non plus
très très très fort très intéressant
mais n'empêche ça a été la mobilisation
citoyenne qui a fait qu' il ya eu cette
convention qui a été mise en place et
je ne dis pas qu'il faut faire ce mode
d'action pour que le si le politique
bouge mais tout et tout est lié aux
citoyens à la participation des
habitants
je garde à l'esprit le souvenir de
l'énergie qu'ils déploient pour faire
changer la vie de la cité quoi de plus
politique à mes yeux
[Musique]
ces citoyens ordinaires ne regarde pas
ailleurs au moment où la maison brûle